[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance somewhere Benjamin Franklin
beige and matthew lyon are saying I told
you so these men went to jail in this
country under our Constitution for
criticism base was in new media Lyon was
a congressman from the party that was
not in power they were guilty of
criticizing the President and other
media which defended the President and
mr. beige and Congressman Lyon would
remind us that we have previously
completely a nearly fatally screwed up
how to handle resistance and they would
remind us that the right to resist has
been destroyed and the country nearly
destroyed with it by better men than
Donald John Trump the man behind the
jailing of baisha and Lyon and 20 or so
other publishers politicians and
citizens one of whom for making a joke
in public the man beige and Lyon opposed
was President John Adams that John Adams
founding father John Adams even a man of
the vision of John Adams could not see
that demonizing descent and
criminalizing resistance could by
themselves end democracy the stains upon
the Adams legacy were called the Alien
and Sedition Acts and they threatened
jail for anyone daring to quote write
print utter or publish any false
scandalous and malicious writing against
the government and 59 days before his
inauguration Trump and his mob are
already clearly laying the groundwork
for a new criminalization of your right
to publicly criticize that which will
begin on day one as the worst
presidential administration in our
history much has been made of the
distraction Trump provided by tweeting
petulantly about how the cast of
Hamilton addressed the Vice
president-elect when he attended their
performance last Friday the criticism of
the coverage paid is valid the fighter
pilots call this chaff spraying strips
of metal into the air to screw up radar
we spent a day talking about [ __ ]
Trump's moronic tweets instead of his
confession in everything but name -
fraud accusations in the Trump
University lawsuit we spent another day
talking about Hamilton and pence instead
of about Trump totally mixing
presidency with his businesses we spent
another day talking about disrespect and
respect instead of yesterday's gaffe
from Trump's voter repression expert in
which he walked into a meeting with
Trump carrying a document easily
readable in the photographs laying out
details of registries religious tests
for people entering this country and
defense against lawsuits we spent
several entire news cycles talking about
actors and rapped and not about the
anti-semites the racists the fascists
Trump is appointing to his white house
the bannon's and Giuliani's and sessions
and their ilk
so scummy it led the great John Cleese
to conclude that it looks as if Trump
quote is assembling the crew for a
pirate ship a distraction yes but that
does not mean his seeming disbelief at
the evidence that he is hated is not
real and not important bluntly if he or
pence cannot handle booing they should
get new jobs in a new country because
whether they hear it or not they will be
booed every day for the rest of their
lives and more importantly that also
does not mean Trump is not intending to
create a 21st century version of the
Alien and Sedition Acts of John Adams a
president elected by a minority of the
voters has again made threats against
those who criticize him or his
administration to be as again made
threats against the first amendment
taken out of the context of the
anti-democratic anti criticism snowball
already beginning its dissent in this
country the takeaways from his tweets
this should not happen and apologize
which seemed merely like more petulance
from the man-baby elect and the
complaint about lack of respect merely
more amazing self unawareness from
president [ __ ] grabber but those tweets
did not come in a vacuum before the
election Trump threatened to loosen up
libel laws singled out reporters by name
to encourage abuse from the crowds at
his rallies promised to sue the New York
Times and an advisor criticized a TV
host and tweeted watch what happens to
her after this election is over the day
after it was over a contestant from one
of his TV shows said of those who did
not vote for him quote mr. Trump has a
long memory
and we're keeping a list responding to
criticism from Senate Minority Leader
Reid Trump's campaign manager Kellyanne
Conway said he quote should be very
careful about characterizing somebody in
a legal sense in a legal sense nine days
after the election a federal judge in
San Antonio swearing in hundreds of new
American citizens told them that Donald
Trump quote will be your president and
if you do not like that
you need to go to another country he
then also lashed out against pro
athletes who have not stood for the
national anthem
then reportedly claimed his remarks were
not political if you would like to
resist by trying to get this judge
rousted his name is John Primo Moe and
he can be removed by the US District
Court or perhaps at least they can send
him the copy of the Constitution he
appears to lack but of course
professional demonizing of dissent
requires blaming the victim campaign
manager Conway said dissent anger
resistance your resistance is the fault
of the media most of the media did the
world a disservice she said by not
preparing them for the possibility of
Donald Trump winning the presidency it
simply was not part of the conversation
so fascism isn't the problem American
media's reluctance to soften up the
public to accept fascism that's the
problem which brings us back to the
Alien and Sedition Acts and a state
senator in Washington named Doug
Erickson allowed Trump sycophants
another one of the banana Republicans
whom our friends publisher Benjamin
Franklin beige and Congressman Matthew
Lyon would recognize immediately I
respect the right to protest he said but
when it endangers people's lives and
property it goes too far
fear intimidation and vandalism are not
a legitimate form of political
expression those who employ it must be
called to account
senator Erickson says he will propose a
bill next year that would criminalize
what he calls violent protesting
creating a new class C felony punishable
by fines of up to $10,000 and or
imprisonment of up to five years crimes
to be called economic terrorism we're
not just going to go after the people
who
these acts of terrorism he continues
still digging we are going after the
people who fund them wealthy donors
should not feel safe in disrupting
middle-class jobs the wealthy donors to
whom senator Erickson refers would also
be liable for any economic loss caused
by the assemblies supposedly protected
by the First Amendment or as Erickson
wants to now call those assemblies
economic terrorism
so Trump's Twitter tantrum about how
Pence was treated at a play about a vice
president so incapable of handling
criticism that he shot the former
secretary of the Treasury may have been
a diversion and it may have seemed
trivial compared to the other nightmares
with which we wake each morning now but
do not mistake them they are preface to
new Alien and Sedition Acts legal ones
or merely cultural ones two new
demonizing of dissent to at best
chilling measures against your right to
resist and how do you resist laws
designed to criminalize resistance
happily there is a method tried-and-true
and you should prepare yourself for it
it worked in South Africa for Gandhi in
1908 when they tried to create a
registry of people from India it worked
for Gandhi again decades later in India
it worked for the civil rights leaders
here in the 1960s if the laws come to
pass do not seek to evade them seek to
break them have them broken so often by
so many people that the jails cannot
hold all of us and the infrastructure
collapses with the government then
begging for our help
moreover if resistance is denied us the
act of being arrested for resistance
becomes resistance because we are not
going back to the time of the Alien and
Sedition Acts matthew lyon
and benjamin franklin base and yes he
was Benjamin Franklin's favorite
grandson they are alive in our history
even Adams and those who supported them
had a kind of excuse the country was
barely twenty years old then Trump and
his mob have no excuse no moral ground
no precedent no right and no chance of
success come after al
resistance Trump legally or culturally
or both an America will kick your ass
resist peace